okay so this is ocean of fear we got
Mark Hamill as wasn't the fear Feaster
yes okay I love that babe
that comes out of Finn's belly button it
tells him that he's afraid of the ocean
and interesting thing to be afraid of
um is not afraid of rivers or oceans
yeah yeah rivers are fine lakes are fine
but oceans for some reason really
freaked him out and so Jake tries to
pretty much like you know bats isn't
through fire just like thrown literally
in the middle of yo we should tie him to
a bed and let him kind of drown in it
and till he gets used to it and but that
doesn't really work and they it's taken
a submarine because the three steps turn
two four five six steps because Jake is
terrible at counting and eventually Finn
mind of overcomes his fears but then the
wise men from his fart I think that yeah
did fart I guess yeah okay cuz I heard a
fart and then this limo comes out they
come and see no no you are brave
everybody has something so you'll be
okay and I think that was it right right
pretty much you also get a good view of
the whole post-apocalyptic yeah
underground you see you see a lot of
buildings there and like buses and cars
that are which I love that cuz they go
down there and like you know is chasing
see the oceans not that basic wow you're
right like this is okay when honestly if
you knew what that was you realize this
is a horrible thing to be like yeah yeah
there's a house where the top is blown
off and you still see the skeleton
family sitting on the couch oh my god
really yeah and actually when he when
they're doing the thing with Jake where
he jumps on Jake and he finally jumps on
that like one little island looking
thing if you look there's tank the tank
and there's a wrecked cruise ship what
yeah I was gonna say cuz the in there
one Episode whatever the the river of
garbage is there a thing like yeah well
I could also sort of be like you know
stuff just might happen all the garbage
in the world whatever yeah and
the one thing I really like in this I
love the slapstick in this one yeah
anytime he jumps on top of Jake and he
just keeps beating and his bread and
butter
which I really like or well some stuff
with the wrench and said yeah no that
was good well if that's one I almost
wonder if because a lot of time sensors
will like be like what you can't do that
that's too aggressive I want that some
well because I'm wondering if when he
hit his head if that was actual career
choice that's what they want to do or if
they said like if sensor it's like now
that sound effect it would be too hard
and we don't want kids really hurting
themselves so just make like a like that
maybe so I've heard weirder stories
there's like really weird sensor stories
but and and then the other thing I
really like about this one is the only I
can describe it as kind of like the ren
and stimpy faces words that you'll get a
lot of wrinkles and see the gums and the
teeth and stuff like that there's a lot
of that from finn in this one it's
really funny well it's just I love it
when like they make the characters look
so scared they just they look like 80
year old demons or something yeah it's
like I don't have this guy or like
whatever those troll faces you see and
stuff like that the cat look like those
and yeah there's just a lot of those in
that that it really cracks me up so
traffic and Mark Hamill's funny you know
he's still he must just have that
slimeball voice down because like it's
obviously not his natural voice but he
whenever he does a voice it always I
mean it's like he really like this
slimeball voice so I thought was great
is that fear Feaster I like to design to
of it I like how I had a mustache yeah
for like no real Reese
so uh no I I thought was good yes one
thing I want to say that I really like
about this there are so many shows you
watch where the characters are
confronted with their deepest fears
and it seems within the matter of 24
hours they're able to confront and
conquer those deepest darkest fears and
it's like okay this show actually does a
more realistic job of someone dealing
with their deepest
even in the end he's still terrified of
that ocean yeah he's not like he's
gotten much better he's gotten deeper no
pun intended into it but at the same
time you're right if he's still like
when he wakes up he's in the oh she's
like oh oh and he's panicking and family
so it is sort of like baby steps but
you're right he hasn't really conquered
it and and like I said there's so many
shows where it seems to be so easy to
conquer your fear and this one it's like
it's like no it's not that easy you're
still gonna be afraid of things and then
the wise men come out and they're like
no everyone has a flaw everyone has a
fear and it's okay that's what makes you
a good person is that you have a flaw
well and what I like about this is that
you know he can't bring himself to go
into the ogee you know he's too scared
but he knows his friend out there so he
just does the only thing he can think of
which is knock himself out go down there
he'll know he knows he'll panic what
he's down there
Matt leaks he'll be down there to help
him so it's yeah I think there is a lot
of truth to that you know I always say
it's I know a really good like character
at least a good hero is not that they're
not afraid of anything but that they're
very afraid but they'll do it anyway
though you'll still go into it and do
what they can to work with their
confront the fear or whatever yeah and
yeah again you sort of you see that here
I mean even if it says silly it's just
not himself found going down the bottom
it's still he's still putting himself in
something he does not really want put
himself through you know and he's like
deathly afraid of but for his friends so
yeah adds up okay know Jory you have
something in common with this episode
secret I can't see him really this does
not mean that I don't shower because I
but it's it's and I really like this
episode because of that it's it's an
irrational fear and and nobody's saying
that it's rational but it is what it is
it just isn't and I love the three wise
men it's alright because we're all
flawed and there's
nothing wrong with that it doesn't mean
you're a bad person it just means
there's something different or kind of
wrongish kind of irrational about you
and we're all irrational and I think
what Jake was doing was kind of and I'm
probably looking too much into this but
like there's something called immersion
therapy yeah no I got those needy people
and stuff and I thought that was really
neat cuz it is kind of in a way I mean
how are you gonna get over your fear you
want to get over it it's not like people
that are scared of you know things I
mean you can laugh at me because I'm
scared of water you know but I can laugh
at you or you you know for being scared
of spiders it's it's irrational I'm not
afraid you know I'm not
uh-huh but the fact of the matter is you
can't if you could fix it just by
thinking well I shouldn't be then nobody
would be afraid of anything
it just it is what it is and I thought
it was a really neat way of showing
everybody for one again it it just
happens to everybody this happens to be
his particular fear is the ocean you're
right
lakes streams it's no big deal I'll
shower I swear I shower I don't think
you have to convince them I think
they'll believe you no answer that now
something I really like to when he's
just like you know all right let's get
started
boom in the house falls apart and
they're in the ocean and I did laughter
that could you write to this or the
immersion therapy just sort of like you
know throw them right into it and just
sort of slowly but surely I guess not
that slowly yeah you know just letting
get used to it Oh see for me was a bit
more of Jake kind of not realizing how
to deal with the fear this is like Oh
guess what
I'm just literally gonna throw you in
the water and guess what step three I'm
just gonna shove you under the water no
it's like he doesn't realize that it's
small steps what if there is it there is
definitely a way and I've seen I've seen
this done before I'm not saying you know
weeks words or
but you know like I've seen people I
have like a horrible fear of bees and
sometimes you know like what they'll do
is that they'll throw them in the middle
of like you know a bee's nest or
something like that and that's the idea
and they tried to talk them through it
and stuff I mean I think the idea is
like once you go through that you know
and come through it okay you know that's
what like the biggest step you can take
but yeah everyone's different so I'm not
if you have like a fear of bees don't I
wouldn't say try that you know but it
has to be it has to be very carefully
done and very you know carefully taken
care of but yeah no I definitely seen
that done before I don't know Jake's
aware it's a method here's the thing is
that part of the reason why I'm so
scared is because that method wasn't
good it was used on me when I was a kid
ago I was already afraid of water and my
mother had this cockamamie
I don't even know who this son of a
bitch was I was really little you guys
and it just put me in the water and he's
like all right we're gonna dump you dunk
even you dunk your head in the water
hold your breath and I was screaming I I
mean I was like really little like maybe
like four or five or something
screaming at the top of my lungs okay
here we go one two three and he like
literally just like dunked me and held
me down I mean there was no I mean it
wasn't like I was in there anyway - I
didn't even want the stupid swimming
lessons to begin with I was clearly
upset and distressed and his idea was
well you're in the water let's get going
no you see why Jori has a very good
connection with this episode
she was been in this episode know I yeah
I know what's stupid and I'm sure and
I'll go in the water I just you know
it's not like I don't know it just it
it's irrational
well since--since you were so brave and
so paid in confessing and stuff like
that I will confess something as well
and it's actually much more embarrassing
than yours and out it's not a Fiat no
it's not a fear but it's something I
can't do okay you said if you can't swim
stuff like that
this is totally true I'm gonna totally
embarrass the
myself right now I can't ride a bike
okay but like here okay here's the fine
thing and people have tried to teach me
I but I had an eye problem outside of
this um you know if you ever wonder why
there's so many misspellings I mean it's
not exactly dyslexia but it's kind of
along those lines
um but yeah so I I didn't keep balance
very well and they tried to teach me oh
just like you know just get to it
another time man cuz it's just getting
dark and everything it just never came
around uh so now I saw where is like a
badge of the right bike so what it's
like my weird quirk or whatever but the
funny thing is that okay when someone
says they can't swim it's like Oh
something whatever you say you can't
ride a bike it's like wrong with you
okay right what the hell yeah we're know
what it's okay swimming like if you fall
in water you needed to survive you know
you need and it's very probable at some
point you know you'll come across water
and need to swim or something like that
but when is there ever a moment we need
to ride a bike to survive okay Tom B
hoard I vomit can use bikes I'm assuming
have you ever have you ever given a
zombie a bike no so you don't know no
maybe they can write no you don't I
would drive a friggin car there faster
and they would pollute the hell out of
those zombies so I'm all for that so I I
never saw the point of what not the
point but like why everyone's like you
know you get right invite that
oh you can't swim you poor thing dude
it's like they're both whatever so
better than you loser loser cuz I can
both ride a bike and swim so well now
there is nothing unique about you there
is no but you're missing out on some you
were missing out on some great pity here
you're missing out a lot of people say
oh you poor thing you're so brave to
come out on the V log and say that just
poor thing and it looks like who's that
jerk who was just like you're a loser I
see now that everyone's gonna hate you
I'm Dyslexic
take that
addresses how weird so it's like can't
write a bi kind of dyslexic can't ride a
bike can't swim slightly dyslexic no I
am just like just like okay dyslexic
yeah and that's all you've got
can we make it so you can't swim either
I'm a peptic there you go go with that
okay yes so here we go three very
screwed up people on this couch slide
yeah
perhaps you should marry each other I
think you two wouldn't need to get a
divorce first more gifts and a
narcissist you from a rope a beard never
would have thought time on the couch
today would actually be time on the
couch I got therapy couch yeah scary
yeah let's go ride some bikes mostly
wrong yeah you go do that I'll go take a
shower
really they really should get divorce